(buzzing)
Sorry.
What's the question?
(upbeat music)
Donald and I do truly love each other.
We've been on speedboats,
we've been in hot tubs,
I attended the wedding to
his lovely bride, Casey.
And we do love each other,
we love each other very much,
I can't lie, you're gonna
ask me if it's ever crossed
certain taboo lines and
I'm gonna say no it hasn't.
Funny story about Rowdy,
I tried to take him home,
he was our dead taxidermy dog,
the network wouldn't let me have him.
And so they put him in a
warehouse and I picture him
like in Raiders of the Lost
Ark where they put the ark
in the back of that warehouse
with all those precious relics
that Rowdy's in the back of some
Disney storage space like that.
Although I did ask them if
I could put him in my film,
Wish I Was Here, have him do a
cameo, he's in the background
of one of the shots in Wish I Was Here.
The studio literally thought
that I was gonna steal
the dead taxidermy animal and
they sent a security guard
with the dog who was his
bodyguard for the day
because they were right, I
would have stealin' his ass.
Going for the butterflies in the stomach.
Got it.
There were so many, I don't
even know where to begin.
I like the ones that were
so random and stonery
like Donald dressed as a
goat, what do you call that?
When someone's half goat, half man?
And he was trying to hit on,
I think he was hitting on
Carey Russell
and I think I, and she
was dressed as a mermaid
and I think I remember saying,
goat Turk, that's my mermaid.
I'm gonna go for the wishbone
'cause I think I can get it.
Oh fudge.
Is that cheating?
Well we're not playing by the real rules.
(chuckles)
Bill Lawrence, our show's
creator, thought the janitor
might just be a figment
of JD's imagination.
Neil, who played the janitor,
didn't even have a major role
on the show, he was doing
a cameo in the pilot.
Neil was so incredibly funny
that Bill made him a regular
and in terms of his name,
no one knew his name.
I think Bill made that up like last season
and to this day, there's
controversy over his name,
whether it really is Glen
Matthews, we don't know.
Okay, I'm going for the broken heart.
Got it.
No but I often get asked by people
and they're not even
kidding, they're like,
you played a doctor for so
long, can you look at this?
And I think they're
joking but they're not,
they think I somehow have
some sort of knowledge
and I just say, put ointment on it.
No matter what it is, even
if it's like a broken arm.
Ointment.
If you're listening out there,
don't listen to my advice,
seek medical help if you
have a genuine ailment.
But first try ointment.
One of the great things about the show
was that Bill Lawrence
let us improvise a lot.
We would always get what
was written locked down
and then we would just play around
and that's where a lot
of some of the audience's
favorite stuff over the years came from,
just so many, of anyone watching
who has a group of friends
who would just joke around
and make each other laugh
and be stupid together,
that's what we were doing
and so a lot of stuff like
eagle and all that stuff
that people like were
just us fucking around.
I got the wrenched ankle
which isn't gonna come out
without a little shake-up
but my friend Danica
says that's cheating.
I pitched a bill that JD
inherits a small amount of money
and that he uses it to
make the Dr. Acula movie
that he and Turk always dreamed of making
so that it would be like a TV
movie or a small miniseries
where they're still
doctors and they're friends
but in their spare time,
they're fulfilling their dream
of making their vampire
medical indie film, Dr. Acula.
Please tweet Bill Lawrence, at VDOOZER,
that you think it's a great idea.
Because he's on the fence about it.
Link to this and say Zach's
idea for the Dr. Acula movie
is genius, what's wrong with you, Bill?
No I'm gonna get the charlie horse.
Got it.
The janitor's wife had limited fingers
and she had used whatever fingers she had
to make me scrubs short shorts
and he wanted me to wear
them and he was very offended
that I wasn't gonna wear
them in the hospital
because she had put all this time
into making scrub short shorts.
And I had to get through the line,
"I'm a doctor, I can't
wear short shorts to work."
And it still to this day makes me crack up
and Neil, just looking at Neil's face,
it was really really hilarious
and you can see the gag reel,
the zillion takes of me
trying to get through it.
I could probably get the funny bone,
the spare ribs are gonna be tough.
The Todd.
The Todd's only real arc was
that you learn that he didn't,
he would have sex with anyone, young, old,
male, female, anything, he was down,
which I think was a beautiful
arc for him over eight years.
I have the Adam's apple
which I'm gonna go for now
'cause I have a prominent one.
Next question.
It's now on Comedy Central
for two hours a day,
four episodes a day, five times a week,
I mean, I'm very surprised
that it's the show
that keeps on going and going and going.
That's pretty cool.
And it's a testament to
how much the fans love it
and so I'm super grateful for them.
That there's no greater job
that laughing your ass off
with your friends all day long.
I spent 8 1/2 years laughing
with my best friends
and then hearing that we were
making people around the world
laugh, I was so blessed to
have that great awesome job
and I just love that it
made people so happy.
Can I get my nose hairs with this thing?
Danica, look away.
She plays by the hardcore rules.
Don't let your kids
cheat at home, everybody.